there's no way out Spencer we were
shocked when we found out that ad was
you Alex and we have to be honest we
have a lot of questions for you
all you wanted was a family right it's
not a family so why did you hurt them we
also have no clue how you got rid of
Wren and we never really understood why
you hated Hanna so much we also have to
wonder if you were behind the Yvonne's
demise
honestly we wouldn't put it past you and
now he's free to be with his one true
love me we still can't get over our love
for Pretty Little Liars but there are so
many unanswered questions from the
original series keep watching to find
out ten of the biggest questions that
were never addressed who shot Spencer
the whole shooting scene was super
confusing some people think that Jenna
was the person who shot Spencer but the
first shot was from uber a or so we
thought were Spencer also that was a
pretty accurate shot and Jenna can't see
we know that Jenna was ready to shoot
Spencer again but that first shot left
us hanging was it ad who shot Spencer or
was it another one of her cronies why
did Alex hurt her sister's Alex does a
lot of terrible things but supposedly
all she ever wanted was a family
this is about money okay it's about
having a home she felt super angry about
her whole being separated at birth
situation Charlotte also just wanted the
family but then they do a lot of
terrible things to Alison its Spencer
it's not their sister's fault that they
were separated at birth it means their
whole reason for being evil makes no
sense I am the power don't you get it no
I don't how did the moms get out of the
basement this is one of the biggest
unanswered questions from Pretty Little
Liars even I Marlene King didn't give a
clear answer the moms were trapped in
the basement all we saw was then having
a lot to drink
yikes they talked about getting out of
the basements but no one ever explained
how they did it did you see any access
to the backyard
couldn't see access to my right hand is
Mary Drake evil Mary Drake is a
confusing character she helped Alex
carry out awful deeds but then she took
the blame to save Spencer she said she
wanted to save Spencer and made Alex
promise not to harm her
but she would never forgive me if you
got out but then she knew that Alex was
planning on it and Mary made a break for
it instead of saving Spencer what is her
deal what's the deal with the dollhouse
the dollhouse was one of the creepiest
storylines ever Charlotte kidnaps all
the little liars and does terrible
things to them in this house ain't
planning on bringing us here the whole
time
to live like his dolls she even
kidnapped Mona but the house was near
town when did it get built and who built
it surely Charlotte didn't build a whole
house by herself and why did no one
notice this house before think that's a
big plot hole keep watching to find out
what question even the showrunner can't
answer how were Sarah and Charlotte
connected we felt sorry for Sarah at
first and then she revealed she was
working with Charlotte all along
she did some truly terrible things for
Charlotte milk instead she is a liar and
a manipulative one of that but why is
she willing to do all this for Charlotte
their relationship was never explained
what was Noelle's motive Noelle's
character was wild
he helped Alison because she blackmailed
him but she never revealed his secret
about pushing a girl down the stairs
when he was under the influence his
family paid the girl off years ago he
got away with her he came back to help
Jenna and Sarah he also helped Charlotte
in the dollhouse
we never understood why he wanted to
help them maybe it was just to get back
at Alison or Aria but his motive was
never clear how did Wilden cover up
Marianne's death
Wilden was definitely a shady cop but
like everyone else in the show he had a
dark secret he was paid to cover up
Marian's death you think somebody paid
him off to lie about how Toby's mom died
but there's a timeline issue here Wilden
is close in age to Charlotte and Marian
passed away in 2000 that means he would
have been just a kid or teenager how did
he get involved with covering it up as a
cop
how did ad have a dungeon ad how did
basement dungeon used solely to mess
with and/or harm people but how did she
have this someone had to build this for
her we don't believe she had the mad
DIY skills to build a dungeon perhaps
Mary helped her with it
so we can leave now and still get away
and they paid someone to build it and
keep quiet about it that's just a theory
because it's never addressed who was
beach hottie beach hottie was the guy
responsible for Alison's pregnancy scare
what am I gonna do it was theorized that
beach hottie was Darren Wilden but it
was never confirmed not even I Marlene
King the show's creator knows who beach
hottie really is
we hope it wasn't Wilden because that is
just creepy do you love shows like
Pretty Little Liars and its spin-offs we
tea to subscribe to the things for more
videos about all the hottest shows if
you're on your phone click settings to
turn on notifications and never miss a
video
who is your favorite Pretty Little Liars
character tell us in the comment section
below if you love Pretty Little Liars
hit that thumbs up button we'll see you
next time
you